وكل هذا عندما يعرضك أبناؤنا وبناتنا للخطر
حياتهم قد ويجب علينا أن نطالب بها
إجابة بسيطة لسؤال بسيط أين هو؟
نحن نقود المظاهرات والاحتجاجات هنا في كفار سابا
لأن شن حرب عادلة لا يمكن أن يكون كذلك
مودعة في أيدي المذبوحين أو في أيديهم
من المتعصبين المسيحانيين الذين كل هدفهم هو الحرب
في زيادة الضيق في استخدام الإنقاذ في حالات الطوارئ كمأوى
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين فشلوا، فإنهم بائسون
أنا
ينص على أنه في كل اجتماع لمجلس الوزراء يتم عرض هذه الشريحة
وتظهر الأهداف القتالية ونحن نعرف الأسرة
نظام حماس، إنكار قدراته العسكرية، أعادها
المخطوفون وأهداف أخرى يراقبها نتنياهو الآن
في هذه الشريحة يبدو لي أنه يرى هدفًا
الهدف الآخر والآخر يراه أمام عينيه
وربما هو في نظره هدف الحفظ
التحالف والحفاظ على حكمه الآن ط
لقد قلتها في هذا الاستوديو وأقولها كل أسبوع
نتنياهو يشكل خطرا على إسرائيل وسأخبركم بالسبب
الآن الأمثلة لأنه في كل مرة يفضل
اعتباراته السياسية على الاعتبارات
الجيش وحتى لا يبقى في جامعتي
سأذكر التفاصيل مع آلة السم الخاصة به على رأس القيادة
مهاجمة رؤوس الجيش تخدش الأهداف
الحرب أو الأهداف السياسية كما والدته
وأفاد أبراموفيتش هنا أن نتنياهو يمنع اللقاء
من رؤوس الأذرع الأمنية أنها تخدش الحرب
أو أن ذلك يخدم أسئلته السياسية عندما يكون هناك
مناقشة مسألة غزة اليوم بعد منع نتنياهو
هذه المناقشة ثم ترفض هذه المناقشة
إنه يخدش أهداف الحرب أو يخدش
أهدافه السياسية حتى لا تزعج سام
ماريتز وبن جفير عندما يسمح نتنياهو بإقالة
مفوض خدمة بيت العاصفة في منتصف الحرب
أنها مسؤولة عن كل هذه الأشياء في منزلي
السجان يخدش الحرب أو يخدشك
أهدافه السياسية ولذلك أقول لك
في الختام عندما يكون هناك الكثير من الاعتبارات السياسية
أن الرجال أو يختلطون في هذا اللون لاعتبارات
تعريض أمن البلاد للخطر الآن سأخبرك
سيرون أنهم مسندون ظهورهم إلى الحائط
ولم يعد المختطفون يشكلون رصيدا استراتيجيا
ليس لقتل المختطفين، بل في المجمل هم بالفعل
لقد قتلوا 1200 شخص، فماذا يهمهم أيضًا؟
140 وهو يرافقني في كل وقت ومؤخرا
أنني سمعت أن الحي الذي أتوا منه يتعرض للقصف
الآلهة الذين ارتكبوا المذبحة في نيرو أقول انتظروا
اسمحوا لي مرة أخرى أن الفكرة تقول أنهم إذا خرجوا
ومنها أيضا المختطفون
ما هو اسمها إذن؟
لكن هذا ما يرافقني حتى الآن وشيء آخر
ما يزعجني حقًا هو الثمن الذي تدفعه الحكومة
الذي سجله في شيف لشهر أكتوبر مستعد للدفع
وقلت كم السعر معلش هعمله
في الطريقة الأكثر صدقا ما هو سعر
هيتو وأنا
لسوء الحظ، أعتقد أنني لا أتفق مع المعلقين الملونين
الهدفين للأسف يتعارضان مع بعضهما البعض
ودولة إسرائيل ملزمة بإحضار جميع المختطفين
المنزل يجب أن يكون أول شيء يتم تشغيله
الطاولة غير مشروطة، بدون تحفظ، بالنسبة لي، لا
شخص آخر سيعيش في غزة، وواحد في غزة بعد الحرب
هذه هي الطريقة التي نحتاج أن ننظر إليها
وهذا كله مهلة مقابل إطلاق سراحنا نحن المختطفين
ويجب الترويج لها في أسرع وقت ممكن، وليس حتى النهاية
القتال ليس أمامنا بأي حال من الأحوال
إبادة الهمز حتى تنتهي نغمة الصقور
حماس في غزة يجب أن تصل إلى الانقراض الفوري لا شيء
ولم يكن من الضروري حساب آخر